Mexico is the new China man I mean I
just had word as an example the Pope the
Pope was in Mexico do you know that -
doesn't even know right
he said negative things about me because
the Mexican government convinced him the
Trump is not a good guy because I want
to have a strong border I want to stop
illegal immigration I want to stop
people from being killed like Kate in
San Francisco like Jamil in Los Angeles
like the incredible woman veteran 65
years old who's raped sodomized and
killed by an illegal immigrant okay so
the Mexican government fed the Pope a
tremendous amount of stuff about Trump
is not a good person and the Pope just
read a statement can you imagine I just
got a call hard as I'm walking up here
they said mr. Trump the Pope made a
statement about you I said the Pope one
of the Pope's say I like the Pope I mean
was it good or bad because if it's good
I like the Pope if it's bad I don't like
the Pope no it's true if and when the
Vatican is attacked by Isis which as
everyone knows is Isis's ultimate trophy
I can promise you that the Pope would
have only wished and prayed that Donald
Trump would have been president because
through it's true because this would not
have happened
Isis would have been eradicated unlike
what is happening now with our all talk
no action politicians that's what's
happening now the Mexican government and
its leadership has made many disparaging
remarks about me to the Pope because
they want to continue to ripoff the
United States both on trade and at the
border it's what they're doing they're
ripping us off and I'm a very good
question because the Pope said something
to the effect that maybe Donald Trump
isn't Christian okay and he's
questioning my faith I was very
surprised to see it but I am a Christian
I'm proud of it okay for a religious
leader to question a person's faith is
disgraceful I'm proud to be a Christian
and as president I will not allow
Christian
to be consistently attacked and weakened
unlike what is happening now
with our current president okay believe
me
[Applause]